aside from being an amazing actress and
i think she's perfect for the show
she's just like the coolest she's not a
lawyer
she's just loud if somebody's gonna be
the lead on the show
you know they kind of set the tone for
everybody but she shows up on time and
she's just
excited to be there you know she's the
kind of leader that you want
she never really does anything that's
that stinks so
absolutely i get to i get to play around
with her and
be her her insane son so i'm
i feel i feel very lucky premiering
thursday rebel has katie playing a legal
advocate with a blue collar background
who may not have a law degree but has a
lot of fearless
know-how if that sounds familiar it's
because the show is executive produced
by erin brockovich
as for kevin he plays katie's doctor son
in the series
you don't even know these people mom
just let it go tell me about this insane
son about this character and kind of
yeah how he fits into the story
her kids are now all grown up she has
four kids and i'm her
her oldest son he's a kind of a weirdo
like his mom
like i think he was raised he's her
oldest so i think he probably was
with her the most he's the least angry
with her not being there as much as
maybe the other kids are
and so he has a lot of like piccadillos
that his mom has he's like
not great in relationships and you know
he's a quirky guy
so they they're much more like friends
than uh
than uh than son and mother
[Music]